need motivation watch the top ten rules
video with the belief nation
what's that belief nation it seven I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
in today's lessons from a man who went
from dropping out of university becoming
a gunship helicopter pilot in the
Vietnam War starting several businesses
and going bankrupt to becoming a
successful entrepreneur and writing more
than 26 books he's Robert rich dad
Kiyosaki and here's my take on his top
ten was a success vol 3
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one master sales I always say the number
one skill of an entrepreneur ability to
sell or communicate number one because
sales equals income so if your sales are
down your incomes down but it's not just
selling your customer you got to sell
your employees that's really tough you
know and then next is selling my
investors so I'm selling investors and
selling employees and selling customers
and I'm selling myself you know I got to
talk myself into I don't have the day I
don't have the pleasure of being down
entrepreneurs gotta be up because if
you're down employees know customers
know at the market knows it so number
one is sales but when you look at the
big picture there's three things an
entrepreneur must learn number one is PR
and what you're talking about is PR the
other the other day Fox News interviewed
me to find out if I would endorse my
friend Donald Trump for president you
know much that's worth you know they
they call branded us
Kiyosaki reg dad and Trump yeah that's
incredibly priceless you know so getting
PR is a number one skill under that is
marketing and marketing does is like
advertising they want to set the
customer up to get ready to buy oh yeah
oh yeah I saw that key I had I want to
buy a Kia I want to buy some land you
know I want to buy you this so the
customer is now primed to buy it that's
marking his job then the last thing is a
sale so if you've done a really good job
on PR then you've done a great job on
marketing the sale is like that you know
they walk in they buy but if you have no
PR and you have no marketing you have to
pound pound
hard close a lot mr. customer you know
you know today's changing business
environment you know you should buy my
insurance you know and people today hate
sales pitches more than ever before
so the number one sales job of a true
entrepreneur is develop your ability to
get PR and I'll say it again most
entrepreneurs are not good at sales
they're horrible at mark and have no
idea what it is and they can't get any
PR and so they struggle and again sales
equals income for the crash rule number
two learned through trial and error what
is an individual that sort of opens
themselves up to learning you know
actually make sure they don't get sort
of roped into the wrong advice and the
wrong teaching well unfortunately as
part of the process you know I've had
bad teachers as well as good teachers
that's part of life that's real life
it's like how do I know she's the right
woman for me should I marry her I don't
know or is he the right man for me I
don't know if you don't know you don't
know and sometimes you don't know until
after you get married it's the same as
money there's no real answer to that the
trouble is those school teachers tell
you there's an answer there isn't an
answer
there's trial and error there's learning
gonna make mistakes I've made a lot of
mistakes but I've never been very good
for me because I've learned from them
but schools tell you if you make
mistakes you're stupid yes when it's
just a poor they don't make enough
mistakes or if they make a mistake they
don't learn from them rule number three
hang out with the best and if you want
to stay small be the smartest guy on the
block and that's why most accountants
most attorneys most doctors never get
rich is because they're too narrow you
know they're experts in toenail removal
you know I mean before my attorney that
kind of poor guys of a a student he
knows jack about side of them whereas I
never had my mother I fought that high
school twice as I can't write its irony
I'm a writer today but the reason I'm
pretty good is because in the military
we're taught to be generalists not
specialists so when I sit down with my
team I have accountants I have attorneys
I have media guys I have IT guys I have
graphic designers and all this so I
operate as a team since I don't know
anything so in actuality being a great
entrepreneur means I could be the
laziest guy and I can know the least but
I have to have a very smart team which
is the ring finger around so because I
was never smart I had respect for people
who are smart and a lot of times I meet
a students and they think that the
smartest guys on planet earth and that
lack of respect what keep them small and
that's what most corporate guys want to
do stay small you know you're gonna
gonna climb that corporate ladder you
gotta beat the other guys with a job and
it's all that stuff it's not the way an
entrepreneur only works it's it's
corporate it's school system you know
you gotta beat up for the great it's
kind of best grades I don't have to be
the best but I have to hang out with the
best rule number four be a good leader
what's your philosophy when it comes to
human resources how do you get the right
people and then how do you keep the
right people that's the most important
part of business you know that's why I
went to military school that I went to I
was a Marine Corps the reason I talk to
military veterans you probably have the
most important skill of all because all
we're trained to do whether you're the
general or a private you're taught to be
leaders it is a number one skill of an
entrepreneur is people skills and
leadership skills and unfortunately most
people don't have it coming into so when
I do my talks to veterans and all the
stuff I really want to encourage them
because if they're pretty depressed
because they can't get it you know
they're law mark reader which is a good
job but they're afraid to take the leap
into entrepreneurship
so but military guys I don't care what
branch of service just by the
indoctrination process and the survival
rate
where they go to combat or not is that
you learn leadership skills people
skills you've got to have that you know
whether whether you're a team of one you
still have to deal your customers and
the good customers bad customers
lawsuits taxes government regulations
and all this they're all people skills
you know so when somebody says to me
what do I need to learn I said boy you'd
better learn how to communicate pretty
quickly to people you don't like
and get them on your side you know how
to win friends and influence people
basic quick the number one skill of an
entrepreneur is people skills rule
number five adjust to change I don't
think the dollar or the RAM will be
around in 50 years but I know gold and
silver and blockchain multi your job is
to figure out which one you're gonna
work for correct this reminds of the
year 2000 you know year 2001 the
dot-coms came on board and there was all
these dot-com companies and everybody
was just throwing if you put you know
Robert Kiyosaki dot-com I could raise a
million bucks well that's where Bitcoin
our cyber currency is today everybody
just throwing money at it and one or two
will survive but I would say 80% won't
survive and so he said it's gonna pay
attention I'll say it again your
competition is the future because it's
gonna change so fast and if you cannot
adjust and change with it then shame on
you yeah that's the way I look at it and
if you think you know all the answers
then I'll pray for you also because I
definitely know I don't know that all
the answers is that I don't i never
invested in Bitcoin but I invested in
aetherium because I have very good
friends who are well well into
investment into aetherium so it does
countable your friends are that you're
going to get rich if you're hanging out
with friends who are poor or family
members or poor or brothers and sisters
or poor your eyes aren't good because
your brain will be too slow for the
future and that what I'm trying to say
also if you're poor today and you find
out about trend coming up you'd be rich
tomorrow but if you're poor yeah you
don't wear anything new you're still
poor tomorrow
so if you know change your friends and
your attitude and your mindset then when
the changes come you don't change with
them rule number six trust your
intuition whistle Bucky fuller said you
must trust your intuition you know and
it's called your gut feeling a lot of
the times and scientists are just
physically found out there's actually a
brain material in their gut that's why
you get a bad feeling and that's kind of
the where intuition comes from or from
your gut rather than your brain and my
intuition can kind of change because I
went to Vietnam twice I was a good
marine Marine US Marine pilot and all
this I was doing it for God country in
America you know all this stuff and one
day I was standing on the battlefield in
1972 and I said what am I doing here you
know why am i killing these people I
don't hate them they don't hate me and
that's when my life you know you started
me started waking up as you grow older
so I learned to trust my intuition and
say what I had to say click like this
book is about the future also follows a
futurist so for me to write Rich Dad
Poor Dad in 1997 early 20 years ago was
about the future it wasn't about 1997
rule number seven work on yourself
pile a set of people hits your mental
skills how do you control your thoughts
emotion because you know I have a bad
temper and I'll lose my temper nobody
likes me so emotion and then it's
physical skills if I look like you know
a bag of dirt I'm not strong people pick
up on that health is important know that
and that's spiritual you know I don't
cheat on my wife I don't cheat on my
customers I don't cheat people I don't
cut corners if I can't do something I'll
tell you up front if I screw up I'll
tell you you know I mean I mean as you
and I know there's a lot of scum out
there or entrepreneurs but they have bad
personal skills they have bad
responsibilities skills they're not
legal ethical moral spiritual and I
think today the way the world's going
better legal ethical moral spiritual
rule number eight become financially
literate I always ask
what did you learn about money in school
and for the answer for most people it's
nothing why learn economics balance a
checkbook but that's really not money
and there is and they don't learn about
money is because the story of Rich Dad
Poor Dad is my poor dad was a PhD it was
chance for poor helpless and desperate
now it's good man but as you know they
don't learn much about money and see my
father knew nothing about money and
that's the problem so we have all these
academic elites you know like Obama and
Hillary and those guys they run the
country with no financial education rule
number nine be prepared
it's your advice to other entrepreneurs
to be searching for a big break and if
so how what's your advice on how to for
them if we're them to position
themselves in the best way to increase
the chances to get a big break well can
I say that matters don't care that five
things going for you
and when you're prepared it happens mmm
but if you're not prepared it doesn't
happen for example you know I was out
here in Ozzie when Oprah called I didn't
start preparing when she called you know
and I was prepared when she fell and my
wife calls up and says hey Oprah come I
go so what she says well she wants you
on a program I go so cuz you know real
men don't watch Oprah and watch all four
not me you know I mean I don't watch
over I didn't know who she was
it's a boy says get your butt home now
so I fly all the way from the bush way
inland from Brisbane to Brisbane to
Phoenix to Chicago and I'm sitting on
over it's too late to practice yeah you
know so but I have done so many PR
stunts and all stuff like this here and
practice practice practice practice
practice and so when all the lights went
on
god this is it it's too late to practice
and I learned that in the military as a
pilot in Vietnam you know I don't say
well I should I should have spent a
little harder before I got to Vietnam I
got practice practice practice practice
practice
because when that ball of Viacom was
shooting at me you know there's only one
guy going home that did him or me
and that is too late to practice and
what happens for most entrepreneurs so
they don't have the skills they don't
practice in there's a very good book
called outliers the story of success I
think it's the best book for
entrepreneurs because it talks how the
Beatles became the Beatles you know they
played war than any other band in
history they played for almost for free
and what Frankfurt Hamburg wherever they
were and the average person doesn't
practice enough okay great advice and
rule number ten the last one before a
very special bonus rule is keep it
simple I will say this to most people
because I'm an old guy having started to
mines myself one silver one gold one in
Argentina one in Japan China it's a lot
cheaper to buy gold and silver I didn't
have to raise 27 million dollars and
then have the Chinese government steal
my mind you know I mean it's like I
couldn't just bought gold on the sofa
with 27 million dollars probably worth
50 million today you know so I like to
keep things simple and nothing too much
that's why I like God's money gold 79
silver atomic number 47 it'll be here
when the cockroaches are did that's all
I think about okay I don't ever sell
gold and silver I just every year every
month I acquire more and it got to be a
big problem because I had to ship it to
other countries because I didn't want
somebody coming stealing from me and I
thought about in banks but I never sell
and that drives people crazy and they go
well how do you not sell if you buy this
toughest as well I use fiat currency to
make money and I use debt I borrow to
buy assets and they go how do you do
that that's an education your practice
you know I play Monopoly every single
day but I use fake money to play
Monopoly
with monopoly by real money which is
gold and silver
I've got a really special bonus tip from
Robert on how to study entrepreneurs
that I think you're gonna really enjoy
but before that it's time for the three
point landing questions time to move
from just watching another video to
actually taking action in your life or
your business and if you're feeling bold
answer these questions in the comments
below here we go question number one
what is your intuition telling you to do
right now number two how will you work
on yourself this week and number three
what are you over complicating that you
need to make simple
the team is the hardest part of the game
you know like that's like okay I'm gonna
take on the Cleveland Cavaliers next
year Who am I gonna who am I gonna put
on my team well my brother-in-law was
fat and ugly yeah you know what I mean
oh yeah have a tea well you better
choose your team really carefully well
you know you know my son needs a job as
a drug dealer but he played basketball
in high school and that's the lunch of
pros do they don't choose our team with
any kind of precision now I made that
mistake you know I brought on like
friends who thought they were
entrepreneurs and they're incompetent
you know they were terrible and I was
terrible also the difference is is when
we failed in their first business I went
on they went back to their jobs a very
big difference in mindset so all I'm
saying here is this if you can
understand this study entrepreneurs like
I studied Edison you know I studied
gates jobs my biggest hero of all his
jobs Steve Jobs I studied at Walt Disney
Henry Ford Tesla you know this guy Elon
Musk this Tesla cart
Elon Musk is the new Steve Jobs I mean
this guy is out of sight smart he knows
to game very well ever if you had to
think of one word that's most important
to you or that sums you Apple that would
be like a little beacon
[Music]
if you want more robert kiyosaki and
want to understand how he invests in
real estate check of the video right
next to me I think you're gonna enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there most people think that savings is
smart but my Rich Dad told me years ago
that savers are losers